hey guys what's up I'm Ilana and my dad  is visiting hi how are you  so worth the IGN offices right now and  I'm gonna have him play live this is  playing a game so it's gonna be pretty  exciting what are you expecting you  ready I'm ready let's do this okay punch  him if you want let me just touch him  that's fine too I don't think it's gonna  work  bye monkey generator you did good job  pull out some resumes maybe you should  copy that see if it works  you excited to be a ship you can pick  that tape up and put it in probably  totally disco  and then play it nice there you gotta  assume the most efficient forms of  humans you're so particular about  putting things back mostly we just like  chuck it sorry  it's your suit did you guys read a lien  on something Oh  just like mama used to make